it was a good idea for Peter King to
catch up with Matt rule the Carolina
Panthers first year head coach and what
a year to become a first-time first year
head coach in the NFL when you've been
in college for years he had one stint in
the NFL as an assistant offensive line
coach with the Giants just figure it out
bro was the quote that Matt roll had to
Peter King basically the mantra at a
time when you can't work with your
players you can't get in the facility
you can't do any of the things that
other coaches have done in past years to
get up to speed Peter give me your your
big takeaway from talking to Matt rule
about the challenges he's facing as he
tries to get ready for a football season
that the NFL by all appearances is
intent on staging well Mike you know not
only is he far and away the least
experienced NFL head coach who was hired
in this cycle you know you got two
former head coaches in McCarthy and
Rivera and then Stefanski and Judge have
worked at combined 23 years on NFL
coaching staffs here's matt rule he
worked for one year as an NFL assistant
coach is you know in between you know
jumping from college job to college job
and not only that but you can't see your
players your your coaches have never met
your players you know I mean he's got a
defensive coordinator Phil snow
he's never coached in pro football he
loses his leader Luke Kuechly and he
can't even meet his players and so all
of this stuff I mean I think it's the
most challenged job that anybody has but
I got him to to email me his speech his
first speech to his team which when you
think about it Mike this is a 2.4
billion dollar business the Carolina
Panthers this is a 60 million dollar
head coach he's the gotten the highest
reward of any first-time NFL
head coach in history they came seven
years sixty million bucks and and all
that happens and so how does he talk to
his team for the first time he props up
his iPhone on a lantern on a picnic
table in the backyard he presses video
and he turns it on and he talks to him
for six minutes and 21 seconds and then
he takes that and he emails it to his 62
players hey here's here here's your new
coach Here I am here's what I believe in
you know and just it just is that's why
he says hey you know just figure it out
it's not gonna be easy for us but I you
know I think he's got a shot not this
year
I think they're gonna be in the Trevor
Lawrence Derby this year but he's gonna
have a shot to rebuild this team because
just remember his first two his two head
jobs one a temple and wanted Baylor they
were the lowest of the low when he got
there and both of them were pretty good
by the time he left yeah that's right
you know and you know anything you hear
about Matt and rule from anybody that
knows them it's a guy that he lives it
you know I think he's been grooming
himself for this chance for a long long
time I know he stays in contact with
guys like Bill Parcells and I think he's
got a few other people who eats kind of
always picking the brain up to you know
figure out how is a better way to do
things advice whatever it may be
he's got great communication skills you
have to if you're gonna be a college
head coach because you got a recruit you
got to talk to parents and kids that way
and to get them to come to your school
you gonna sell yourself sell the school
so he's good at that and I think the big
thing is to what Peter said in the last
point is spot-on
yes it's the NFL but he understands how
to build a team I mean to take temple
where it was and then Baylor was
absolutely in the crapper okay for lack
of a better phrase there I mean it this
is like everything was hello London it
looked like everything was bad there and
then he comes in there and gets some
players and turns it around to where
they become a power in the big 12 which
is like I thought Baylor was gonna be
gone and you know dead
for a while before we hear from them
again so and I think he's done a lot of
great things here early on about
flipping the team over about that
team-building that Peter brought up I
mean he didn't try to like oh let me see
if I can squeeze a few more years out of
this last football team and he just said
no you know let's cut the cord let's
start getting young talent in there I've
seen a lot of this young talent through
my recruiting and my college days and he
knows what he wants her his football
team and I think they had a very
impressive free agency and draft this
year I'm reminded of the on-field
encounter in 2011 between then Lions
coach jim schwartz and then 49ers coach
Jim Harbaugh and that exchange after the
49ers beat the Lions in route to a
thirteen and three regular season had
its roots in an offseason dinner
involving Schwartz and both Harbaugh
Brothers and the way that John Harbaugh
tells the story Swartz was basically
saying to Jim you've got no chance this
year there's a lockout you have you're a
first-year coach you're coming from
Stanford before that you're at the
University of San Diego you're not gonna
do anything this year and Jim sat there
and stood and stood and stood some more
and that all exploded on that day in
October 2011 when the 49ers beat the
Lions but the 49ers turned it around
dramatically Peter
I get the impression you're ready to
right off the mat rule Panthers is there
a chance that he could take a page out
of the Jim Harbaugh playbook from nine
years ago I mean there's a chance
obviously but you know look they might
have who knows what this year is gonna
look like they might have a month once
you can all get together before they
start playing games and just remember
they've got five of their first 10 games
are against division foes so Brady Brees
Matt Ryan I mean you know everybody okay
so Brady and Brees obviously you're
going to the Hall of Fame if Matt Ryan
plays five more years five more years
and his current level of production he
will retire with more passing yards than
Peyton Manning and Brett Favre
so I mean it's not like playing the
Falcons is a day off okay so so I may be
Mike
maybe but I think this is probably more
of 2020 as a building year and 2021 and
beyond especially if they're in position
to draft one of those really good
quarterbacks if hey look teddy
bridgewater might you you know who might
be able to prove it
that they shouldn't take a quarterback
so we'll see yeah that's right they well
you know I'm more with Peter Mike here
on this one where I think this is a year
about laying down the tracks or
something better in the future you know
the fact that all they did in the draft
was draft defensive players you know you
look at that the Teddy Bridgewater
situation of course that quarterback I
do think gives them some flexibility I
think it was a brilliant move by that
really because when you get a guy like
Teddy Bridgewater yeah you might go go
damn we we struck gold he's our guy we
got him going forward but if it doesn't
really work out you'll also be able to
sell the ownership and go where you know
he was kind of a career journeymen I
just wanted him as a stopgap guy now we
need to get my franchise quarterback in
here that's gonna buy him time and some
wiggle room with ownership as well but
you know as much as hey the defense is
totally flipped over the offense you
know Mike this is where I kind of find
them exciting and fun you start to look
at their names and some of the young
talent they got on this offense it
excites you I mean you look at those
three receivers they got DJ Moore Robbie
Anderson and free agency and Kurtis
Samuel those guys can fly I mean that's
special then Christian McCaffrey and
what he does in the pass game and run
game you know that's where they're kind
of excited and I think can be a pain in
the butt for a lot of teams in the NFC
South in the NFL in general I think the
wild card in all of this and emphasis on
the wild is owner David Tepper I mean he
is not afraid to do what he has to do to
maximize his position he's earned
billions via his hedge funds and I look
to me last year when they got down to
the last two games and they decided to
throw will Grier out there that was
in a roundabout way an effort to improve
their draft standing in 2020 the David
Tepper gets it that he understands the
the disconnect that the NFL tries to
sell between winning every single game
but oh boy it's great to be as high as
you can be in the draft order and I
think they will start this season with
every intent to try to win games and
I'll doing a full season tank but the
moment it begins to fall apart David
Tepper is not gonna stand in the way of
it falling apart because he's gonna
understand the benefit to the
organization 2021 and beyond if they can
get in position to get at Trevor
Lawrence or another top quarterback and
revolutionized the franchise that way
but but but you know like you guys have
said hey if Teddy Bridgewater ends up
getting it done they've got Christian
McCaffrey in his prime they're not just
gonna flush the season from the get-go
but I think they'll be ready to pivot to
alright let's be as bad as we can be in
the hopes of drafting as high as we can
from the standpoint of winning and
losing games if their effort out of the
gates to be competitive doesn't work
Peter
yeah and look the specter of and and
he's right in their area obviously
specter of Trevor Lawrence is going to
hangover this season this NFL season and
the Carolina Panthers season and I don't
think as you say Mike that they're going
to start off doing this because look
last year you know the Miami Dolphins
proved that you know because what do
they start owing seven the Miami
Dolphins prove that you know they've got
a better record after Halloween than the
New England Patriots and what that
proves to me is that a coach and an
organization can do whatever it wants
and the Miami Dolphins do they wish
today they had Joe burrow on their team
yes but that wasn't the way it was and
so they might want to have it this way
but once players and coaches get
involved they're going to understand
that you know the Carolina Panthers are
not gonna have the worst record in
football they won't you know maybe
they're gonna have
maybe they're gonna have a needy defense
but that is going to be a good offensive
football team and I think they're gonna
be they're gonna be decent what does
decent mean five and eleven you know six
and ten I don't know but they're not
gonna be two and fourteen yeah I don't
expect them to be that either I don't
you know and listen there's a lot of
unproven commodities you know of course
across the board the young talent hey
Joe Brady first time you know NFL
offensive coordinator defensive
coordinator that you mentioned never
coached in the NFL before of course bat
rule first time being a head coach in
the NFL so they're gonna have to find
their way you know and you know I think
the big thing is it Mikey we brought up
like the San Francisco 49ers and Jim
Harbaugh in 2011 listen that team you
know was kind of set up and ready to go
for Jim Harbaugh he was very fortunate
that way and also Jim Harbaugh you know
played a brand of football that was
simple and it fit the team that way to
to me this is where one of the balancing
acts of football will be this year you
know the coaches that can find the line
of like okay we want to push forward and
put more offense and be more creative
okay that's cool but at one point
because of the lack of offseason time
are you going to endanger yourself or
your team of going wait that's too much
and we're not being detailed than any of
these schemes and we're not executing
and doing those things right yeah hey
great you know we got a hundred
different pass plays but we mess up 87
of them all the time that's not good
you're gonna have to find where a guys
especially cannot rule is enough that to
find that fine line to go okay I think
this is we push the boundaries of
creativity but also this is where my
team's really comfortable and we're
gonna make no mistakes and we could
really execute and play a perfect ball
that way to where our team won't mess it
up you know Matt rules gonna have to
tinker with that and you know to a
little more to what Peter said too you
know I just think it's hard for a coach
like this to Mike if he's even somewhere
in the inkling of being in the playoff
conversation early November mid-november
you know those teams they're they're
just they're not going to give up and as
we talked about before the records for
these head coaches they go on their
tombstones so they have a hard
I'm pulling the plug on a season 4 draft
it's a very tough you know angel and
devil on their shoulder there with that
conversation
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports